[Music]
well it's a great pleasure and privilege
to introduce another genuine pioneer
another person who's really helped shape
our field in a multiplicity of ways Bob
Kahn was primarily responsible for the
design of the ARPANET which was the
first practical realization of packet
switching which was rather a
controversial thing at the time people
first started advocating it he was also
responsible for initiating the internet
project at ARPA which was the follow-on
to ARPANET and that was the first open
architecture Network another very
important idea
he's a co-inventor of the tcp/ip
protocol which provides the framework
for the Internet
now that's one role in which he
functioned as key designer scientist
engineer another was that he was a
enlightened funder of the ARPA academic
community and he was responsible for
initiating and funding many star
projects and stars and were all in his
debt he's been a tireless champion of
computers and communications and that
interplay that is so important to us
today he left ARPA for a very specific
purpose to found and he's now president
of the corporation for national research
initiatives which he founded in 86 to
provide leadership for the research and
development that he felt would
absolutely be vital for the national
information infrastructure the NII
or as it became later known the
information superhighway or the info
bond or whatever your favorite buzz word
is that that would take in order to be
more than just hype to be reality and to
be useful to all of us and he is still
engaged in working those research issues
now bringing it back to our theme today
Bush had very little to say about how
people work together the idea of sharing
or as
now says transclusion was certainly in
there but it is almost hidden away and
you really had the sense that he was
working on personal information
management devices but sharing
information is obviously the name of the
game today and spools of annotated
microfilm in the mail is not how we
fortunately have to do things today he
simply did not anticipate computers and
communications as it has grown up and
Bob's role here today will be to talk
about ways in which to extend Bush's
vision Bob would you have any serious
objections if I took your laptop off of
the podium here just can't resist a
keyboard okay
well first of all I am delighted to be
here at this session honoring the 50
years of pushes paper and particularly
happy to be on the the program after
both Ted Nelson and Doug Engelbart I
have to tell you though that I think it
would have been much nicer if you put
them on in the reverse order because
every time I listened to Doug I feel
nice and smooth and relaxed and when I
hear Ted I feel like I need to lie down
no just you know Doug reminds me of kind
of a cyber psychologist I always feel
like sort of probing and every time I
listen to Ted it's sort of a hybrid I
keep going back and forth between Back
to the Future and Saturday Night Live
when when I was asked to give this talk
and II sort of said look anything you'd
like to talk about would be would be
fine as long as it's in the context of
Bush's paper because that's what the
symposium is about and I got the
thinking about the real guidance I got
because listening to both Doug's talk
and Ted's talk I sort of got the
impression that the guidance from Andy
to Doug may have been to only talk about
ideas that have been well thought about
for the last 40 years and which of
course Doug has been doing over and over
again and in listening to Ted I sort of
had the impression that he said don't
talk about any idea that you've had in
the last 35 years so focus only on on
stuff that hasn't evolved since then to
me when I first suggested what what
about the internet and I talked a little
bit about packet switching he says no no
that's sort of retrograde stuff talk
about the future sort of look at look
look into what the future is likely to
produce and I said well then how about
something about the framework for
digital object services which is sort of
where things are currently at in my way
of thinking he says no that sounds too
much like a computer science seminar I
really want you to sort of speculate
about the future which I translated to
mean don't talk about any idea that
you've ever thought about before you
show up on this podium and that's been a
little bit hard to do so I won't keep to
the letter of that particular guidance
but I'll do my best
[Music]
let's see when when you look at the
paper that Bush wrote and I read it now
many many times and
on the one hand it really is very
prescient about some of the needs and
requirements and desires and ideals that
we might have in the future
I'm particularly impressed about his
notion of what reality is
I mean his reality is totally embedded
in the inventions of the day or the near
term he talks a lot about photocells and
advanced photography he talks about
thermionic tubes you know he talks about
typewriters he's sort of locked into the
the stuff of the day as it were he
certainly doesn't talk about digital
technology and I want to get into that
in the future he has a very strong focus
in his particular writing on scientists
and so what's left for the scientific
community to focus on
he certainly has pointed to the
information overload problem which
certainly must be greater now than it
was then but it's nice to know that it's
not a new problem
lissa gives us some hope if we haven't
solved it in the last 50 years we have
some work to do in the next 50 he talks
a lot about sort of linking of ideas but
when you looked at the machinery that he
was talking about dealing with it tended
to be more grounded in logic than it was
in higher-level notions more semantic
context and perhaps he really believed
that some somehow higher-level ideas
could be put into the context of logic
as many people have proposed on certain
axiomatic basis and he I think
emphasized very strongly the human
dimension as he got into the notion of
mimics and where it could could lead
through some of his ideas like trails
and so forth but as I look at what he
wrote about in the paper I'm also struck
by what it was lacking as well as what
it was prognosticating upon it was
really very strongly lacking in digital
technology and
we heard even from some of the members
of the audience that you know perhaps he
was not all that comfortable with
digital technology because it really
kind of arose from around him but not
from within him personally it's
interesting also that the paper was
dated in in the year in which or
certainly in the decade in which
computing first really emerged as a
workable invention not to say that
people haven't thought about it before
and hadn't poked around with it but I
think the 40s was really the year the
early workable machines and the 50s the
first really practical ones and then
after that it really got commercialized
seriously he was also there for embedded
in a world of analog devices he was
focused on where the science community
went and of course he was also well
grounded in the physics community of the
day which at the end of World War two
saw its mission coming too to an end
potentially I think we have some of the
same similarities today but a very
different possible roll out you know
just as the end of World War two offered
serious questions and challenges for the
scientific community so - today does the
end of the Cold War offer some serious
challenges for the entire scientific
research community in this country
because we have come to the end of
what's been a very long 50-year compact
between the federal government and the
research community in the sense that a
lot of the research that was supported
over that period was predicated on the
need to do it because of the Cold War
and while that's by no means a
suggestion that the federal government
won't continue a compact with the
research community it's pretty clear to
me that it's being reformulated as we
speak and nobody yet knows what the
shape and form of it is I'm particularly
hopeful that it will come out with a
strong support as we've had in the past
but it's by no means guaranteed so there
are some pair
oles between what we've seen in the past
and what we're seeing now
the fortunate thing in in Vannevar
Bush's time was the fact that he had
this this future that was unveiling
itself as he was writing his work today
you could say that some of the same is
happening I could argue that we have not
yet really seen the innovation that's
going to really change the world of the
future maybe we have it in our heads and
it hasn't come out or maybe it's
happening around us and some of us don't
know about it the absence of digital
technology in his vision it seems to me
led to a very limited view of what was
doable and what was not doable in the
1972 when I played at the very first I
Triple C conference a tape about the
ARPANET and the origins of packet
switching a lot of the people who were
very active and have stayed active in
the field were on that tape and had we
done a retrospective of I would have
played it for you here today in part if
you listen to that tape what you will
hear is that the communication folks
speak in very timeless phrases they talk
about the need for connectivity high
bandwidth highly reliable systems and
you could play it today and say it's
today's challenge just as well when you
listen to the folks who are more
grounded on the computer side of the
world and I think the distinction was
larger then than it is today almost
everyone was talking about the
technology of the day and so almost
nothing that they said really translates
easily into today's context because it's
dated so you would see people talking
about the need to connect a high power
graphics display to a powerful remote
time sharing system as their aspiration
for the future today nobody would argue
that nobody talked about
much of the technology that Chernov
because it just didn't exist they talked
about better use of the technology they
then then had but they were very clear
about the role of software in this and
this whole thing well where are we today
I say still in a very embryonic State we
are rapidly converting to digital but
let's do you think that we've made a lot
of progress today we are barely there
today if you can imagine a
not-too-distant future when we might
have let's say upwards of 60 million
people on the Internet
keep in mind that that's likely to be
less than 1/10 of 1% of the world's
population so that the actual size of
the the population that were or maybe
it's 1% but the size of the population
that we have to deal with is much much
larger than people who are now
experiencing this particular technology
and as the technology gets out the
biggest problem I think we're going to
have to deal with is the cultural
distinctions between the network itself
and what it implies and the physical
reality that we all deal with on a daily
basis so let me separate these these two
things and talk about the physical
reality and the network and give you
some notion of the kind of cultural
disparity that exists between these two
worlds and I've experienced it myself in
a number of different contexts it's come
up in some of the dealings with the
financial community when they have
largely in the past and most people
think about using networks as a vehicle
for moving information about money what
they don't realize is that you can also
have a notion of money that exists
wholly within the network itself has no
necessary physical counterpart on the
outside so you open up your wallet you
take out a string of bits you hand it to
somebody else and you've done the same
thing
let's take out a dollar bill and hand it
to them that is it need be no physical
account anywhere
in the world that knows about that
dollar bill or knows about these bits
and yet you can pass them around maybe
even make change for them well when you
describe that to people who are somewhat
sophisticated about digital technology
very first thing they think about is you
must mean passing information about it
no matter what words you use it's very
hard to to think about anything else
second example I would give you is in
the working that we've done with the
library community where the library
community traditionally has been very
paper-based they deal with ebooks they
deal with stacks of material and their
notion of the network is it's a way of
taking that paper world and dealing with
that information in a more flexible
flexible way and so what they tend to do
is take their thoughts and their their
approaches that were well developed and
in the paper world and try and bring
them into the world of of the network
oftentimes at the at the loss of all the
new flexibility that you could get if
you rethought it completely anyone who
has ever tried to take a book and put a
book on the network in anything more
than just showing the pages one after
another or letting you move through them
more flexibly you know realizes that the
design of something for the network
world can be very different different
challenge than the design of something
for the paper world and I'm not talking
about just the ability to do hypertext
linking and things like that the very
nature of that experience can be very
different so the heart of the problem as
I see it in this particular cultural
context is getting people to understand
that when you're in the network you may
be having a different experience than
when you're outside and so there's the
whole idea of where you're grounded when
you're grounded in reality the network
is a tool when you're grounded in the
network then sort of reality becomes
your tool as it were you sort of have
things flip around completely so this
shows up in
a number of different domains but let me
just start out by talking about
creativity in the digital world
for starters people that we deal with in
the various industries that are a
content oriented today know that when
they produce you know a work in paper
form or if they record something it has
a reality in the physical world and when
it gets translated into the digital
world they want to think of it as being
the same thing a lot of laws that apply
in the physical world that they'd like
to apply in the electronic world and
maybe that's the right way for it to
come out politically doesn't have to
come out that way
technologically there are people who can
create things in the digital world that
is to say if you are a creator of a
musical work there's no need necessarily
for that work to first show up in audio
recorded form before it ever gets
transduced into any way that's captured
and stored in memory that is you can
create a totally in digital form with
that anybody ever having heard it before
and in that sense it's got different
properties than it might if it were in
the normal analog physical world the act
of converting something from the
physical world to the digital world is
to some a trivial mechanical contrivance
just a matter of scanning some bits
digitizing some bits but what you end up
with is something that is uniquely
different in many ways it's manipulable
in different ways it's processable it's
transportable there are things that you
can potentially do with it in fact it
may be a very new contrivance all all on
its own you know I'm reminded of the
discussions that I've had with my wife
who happens to be a copyright lawyer
about the history of some of the key
developments in this field and you know
I was particularly struck with how
difficult it was to get people to
realize that a motion picture was really
a different kind of thing than just a
series of images and yet well in this
country
we recognize the existence of the motion
pictures a audio-visual work of a
different kind than just a collection of
images because it does have a storyline
and it does convey a different
experience there are countries around
the world for which motion pictures are
protected as just a very long series of
images and there is no other attribution
given to them beyond that so one of the
hypotheses I want to put out is that in
general this may not be the true in
every single case and this is certainly
not a statement about how law should be
written but the fact of the matter is
that digital representations of things
are in fact literary works they are
putting together things in terms of
sequences of symbols which is what a
literary work is we tend to put them
together as sequences of the alphabet
which are non processable except by a
human brain and and system looking at it
you know potentially English could be
processable by a machine in the future
according to some rules but when you
write computer programs and you're
executing on digital representations you
in fact are dealing with literary works
in a program field according to my
reading of the law today whether that is
something that would be universally
accepted or not this is a different
issue but it seems to be the case now
when you talk about a digital
representation interesting word there is
not so much digital but representation
because it implies that what you have
inside the system is a representation of
what was outside the system
and what do you do when you start out
with something that's inside the system
to begin with well it's not clear it's a
digital representation of anything else
it may be the the the first and only
fixation it may have an analogue
representation of the digital original
if you will but it may not be a digital
representation of something that was
outside like a digital representation of
an image or a movie or whatever
furthermore
as we move to an all digital world my
assertion is that our grounding in
reality is going to be lost in a very
fundamental way in the sense that as we
get into more and more activities that
involve multiple participants enabled
through this digital medium everyone
will be able to be involved in
participate witness view experience a
given event or set of events in their
own unique way now you might say we do
that today all by ourselves and an
arbitrary camera though could record the
facts as they were so the facts of the
particular setting could be recorded on
film and we would say that was the
reality but in a digital space maybe you
can't get to a single place that was the
thing that produced the experience that
everybody had and since they all saw it
differently
Rashomon phenomena are likely to abound
in multiple ways so that may in fact be
no real reality anymore
just multiple perceptions of the same
thing coming together well when you look
at Busch's notion and you realize that
digital technology didn't fit in his
world you realize that he was pushing
pretty hard and in a rather remarkable
way figure out how all these analog
pieces of technology could play into
this future but when we look at it today
that range of technology almost is not
on the on the visibility scene we have
semiconductors and electronics more
generally my guess is that in time even
that technology may be superseded by
something else I mean we're all looking
at optics and photonics but that may not
not be the last word in terms of
materials and material phenomena in fact
as we move to faster and faster and
smaller and smaller
we may get from our current views where
we're talking about moving things to
actually manipulating things in smaller
and smaller worlds as we get into the
ability to manipulate the the nanoscopic
and smaller on the networking front the
issue is somewhat similar to computing
in the sense that I think computing as
we know it as a machine that's able to
manipulate symbols on our behalf
will be around probably forever
networking in terms of its ability to
provide reliable connectivity between
different parties will probably be
around with us forever
and I don't think those are likely to be
be taken for granted anytime soon and
maybe in the future it will and so when
you look at what is possible within this
framework begin to realize that while
many people are pushing the technologies
and and we get amazing developments
almost every every year in fact the real
action is likely to be in the systems
and the application side of the world
will we try and put these things
together in interesting ways that take
real advantage of the power of the
networking and the power of the
computing capabilities both the
equipment themselves and all of the
peripheral devices that go along with it
everybody here probably would view
progress in networking in terms of a few
simple measures like bandwidth moving
from 56 kilobits or 300 baud for those
old timers to one and a half megabits or
a gigabit or a terabit or a pet a bit
and I run out of Greek prefixes at some
point here so we could probably help on
the computing side software is still too
hard but the real challenge is putting
it together it's the integration
function and as you think about the
integration function you realize that
the idea of integration
ultimately it's gotta be more than just
plug and play that is plug and play sort
of presumes that somebody has figured
out what the architecture is for
coherence beforehand and put out this
technology in a form that you can just
plug it and things will work but this is
unlikely to be the way things actually
work it's unlikely to be the way things
work at the technology level it's
unlikely to be the way things work at
certain dimensions of the human
interaction level and it's unlikely to
work that way at the content level now
if I could have the first of the slides
just want to give you the NII example of
how this integration can and cannot play
out there are a lot of people who think
that the NII the so-called national
information infrastructure is a kind of
thing that we need and we might consider
putting out a an RFP to somebody to go
build it like a building so it's got an
architecture that's below it but in fact
it's probably more organic than that to
really be effective it needs to have the
kind of dynamism that the economy might
have where you can capitalize on ideas
from different sources put them together
so that the whole is greater than just
the sum of the parts
but this slide illustrates one model of
an an I I that might come out of our
combined activities but what is this
it's a very uninteresting notion of an
NII it is more like what we would define
the economy to be namely the set of all
activities that are in while production
and consumption social and otherwise in
our system here's the same thing for the
NII you simply take the collection of
technologies and applications and all
the things that people produce and all
the things that people consume put a
circle around that and call that the NII
if that's what we end up with we will
have failed to leverage the real
possibilities of this revolution in
computers and communications that we're
experiencing the infrastructure is
absolutely crucial and the reason it's
crucial is that if it's done right it
can lower the barriers to productivity
in lots of different
you've heard some examples already from
some of our speakers but we haven't
really had a national level
infrastructure despite the fact that
we've had a telephone system in this
country for a long time I heard one of
my colleagues say this was a
hundred-year mistake and going from all
digital technology and the Telegraph's
of all analog technology and now back
again but that's another matter we may
in fact go through this cycle again and
again as we consider whether to move to
an all optical plant which is not yet
clearly digitized so we may move back to
an all optical one at some point in the
future only to realize the power of
digital technology in the network and
then figure out how to gain the power of
that through some physical invention of
which I can barely begin to comprehend
at this point so you have you have this
this conundrum if I can have the next
slide this is sort of the dream that
many people have that you take all of
these different capabilities that are
going to be part of the NII and they go
through a magic convergence process
don't ask me what it is I saw a
wonderful film on the notion which kind
of made funny that this whole notion as
to whether it's possible but I would I
would describe the first slide as being
akin to putting out an RFP for a
symphony asking for violin oboe first
cello pieces and saying that they can be
no more than 30 minutes in length and
have a dynamic range of 60 DB and then
you take the you take the ones that look
nicest on the screen you should add them
together and you call that your symphony
their problem is it's missing something
and I don't know what to call it exactly
it's not the architecture of the
symphony but it is sort of the musical
work that was presumably in the symphony
in the first place so you're not going
to get that musical work by linear
addition it isn't going to happen except
that unless the monkeys enough monkeys
submit musical compositions so how is it
going to happen well one way it could
happen is if you know
magically Mozart could figure out what
the NII symphonies are for each of these
different areas and come out with the
right prescriptions for what the elbows
and the flutes and so on should be
playing but the N III is so big and
broad that Mozart needs a pretty dynamic
range to be able to cover all these
bases and I don't know anybody who's
brought enough to cover absolutely every
one of the bases and maybe there are
some who can cover some of them but we
don't even know what all the bases are
so how are you going to get to this
convergence and more importantly how are
you gonna get gonna get anybody to agree
to this notion of of convergence I think
it's going to be very hard I want to
come back to this because the key to
this working is is open architecture in
my book in my view and it seems to me
that the notion of open architecture is
not necessarily something that is going
to be unanimously agreed to a priori we
may agree to an open architecture a
posteriori wants all the standards and
interfaces and the like are sort of
sorted out in the marketplace but if I
can have the next slide the more likely
scenario is that we will have some
degree of convergence in some limited
domains initially and that will have a
lot of separate efforts by different
groups some with vertical integration
and some not and some of those two
things in fact will be what we decide to
call the NII now as as you think about
the open architecture issue let me let
me try and describe this in in internet
terms when I was first working on the
Internet architecture I described it to
a large number of people as an open
architecture approach to networking
basically says anybody can bring their
own notion of a network you can plug it
together and somehow the whole thing
will seamlessly work to do best efforts
delivery of packets from source to
destination and doesn't matter what the
network technology is furthermore you
can have value-added service providers
come and provide their own networks in
fact the whole thing could be
commercialized at some point and still
allow for evolution of the technology
well in the early 70s
we had one large communications company
in this country and the idea of them
building an open architecture network
for lots of other people to participate
wasn't exactly in their game plan at the
time and in fact I suspect broadly
speaking even for people who would have
been open to that idea it didn't mean
anything to them they didn't know how to
relate to it I could see similar
parallels to people trying to relate to
hypertext when their only model of the
world was a book but when you're trying
to relate to a network you think about
how you put it together how's it gonna
work well what's the issue here nobody's
really in charge the framework is
responsible for keeping it working there
might be a process through which
evolution can take place but nobody
really is running it it just did have
the ring of truth nothing this important
to our society should be run that way
except the economy maybe or a few other
things like that so it just didn't have
the ring of truth back back in those
days to anybody didn't understand it so
where are we today you take the area of
electronic transactions which libraries
will fall into an electronic commerce
would fall into it all of those things
and you say what we really need is an
open architecture for digital libraries
let's say and everybody says yeah that's
fine but then they glaze over because it
doesn't mean anything to them they don't
know what does it mean I say well it's
really simple you bring your own library
to the thing and it seamlessly becomes
integrated in the whole say yeah great
idea and you go on to your next thing
because it doesn't translate into a
technological plan of action and even if
it did it doesn't translate into a
political systematic commercial plan of
action either at least that's the way
most people would look at it so you go
to someone who is in the database world
and say this is what we want to say we
have the answers called distributed
database technology that's what it does
except it's my distributed database
technology
and say well we want to take your
distributed database technology and make
that an open architecture is it wait a
minute that's where our value-added
stuff comes in and we can't possibly do
that and make it available to anybody
else and I'm going to come back to this
in the context of content in the middle
because there's an analogous notion of
an open architecture for dealing with
content but let me do that in due course
so here you have this issue of open
architecture which i think is important
but you have to realize that that there
are many people in industry who would
look at open architecture and say that's
what we get after the whole process of
sorting out the marketplace is over and
if you try and do it upfront it
precludes any single industrial giant
who thinks they can do the whole
vertical slice from weighing and taking
over the market so some people think
it's a good idea and some people think
it's a bad idea but I think it's the
only way you can get this organic growth
into a very large system where everybody
has a chance to participate well then
you think about all organic growth and
that leads you immediately into issues
of adaptability if I could have the next
slide I've got some of these points I'm
going to touch on outlined here ok so
I've already talked about digital
technology and I'm going to come back to
a couple of the points there but I'm
sort of jumping down right now into
adaptive behavior the the most important
thing you want in in any system and
again I'm thinking of network in the
broad sense of including not only the
communications and all the different
pathways but also the machines that may
be connected to them and when I talk
about communications I don't only mean
terrestrial lines I do mean Wireless
over-the-air I do mean all of the
different media that one might use in
order to get information from one place
to another
electronic optic or whatever and I would
even include in this open architecture
the possibility of non permanent
connections so that people can in fact
exit from the system and plug back in
and still keep things going so you'd
like this kind of system to be able to
adapt its
and ideally you'd like it to be able to
adapt itself in some intelligent ways
how many of you know of any systems that
really have a detailed awareness of what
it is that they're doing and the answer
is almost none I mean they might know
for example in the phone company how
much loading is on their line so they
may keep some traffic statistics but in
terms of what's really going on they
really don't have have a notion or any
idea of how they can then configure the
net to do a better job of dealing with
this to give you an example of how you
could get a better idea of awareness or
even learning let me hypothesize that in
the world of the future which might lead
to very very complex functionality or
might not that individual components in
the net may have the ability to know
what it is that's going on a given wafer
for example might no longer be just a
set of electronics carrying out a
function but could in fact be multiple
levels where level one in one example
might be carrying out the functional
level two might be overseeing the
function carried out by the other level
now if something goes wrong at one level
the other one might know about it may be
able to fix it and so forth
likewise you can have synergistic
implementations where both levels are
product providing functionality and also
at the same time keeping track of the
others and that's only a two level model
you can have trivial models that have
more than two levels dealing with this
replication and just checking to make
sure how many you're doing the same
thing but that's not really very smart I
think we can we can do better than that
so I think the idea of incorporating
adaptive behavior in the net is an
important one
another thing that becomes important I'm
going to come back to this later is the
possibility of injecting intelligence
into the net that is to say today we're
living in a world where everything that
happens inside the system is principally
controlled by the person who built it
brought it to you runs it operates it
there are very few cases where the
intrinsic operation of that system is
allowed to be controlled by arbitrary
people from outside sending in the
equivalent
as it were intelligent agents in the
system that could affect its performance
this smacks too many people of allowing
viruses to come in
it raises all the issues of trust and
control it raises all the issues of
scoping and and so forth but it seems to
me it's in our it's in our future before
I get off of this slide let me jump up a
couple levels and just touch on a few
other points they didn't make on this
slide one is that Bush and his article
talked a lot of doubt capturing
information from everywhere I mean he
talked about I don't know walnuts on
your forehead or if I forget exactly how
we put it
microfilm just sort of snapping pictures
everywhere you know hidden shutters in
your pocket the fact that matter is we
are rapidly getting to the point where
every one of us can make digital
fixations of everything that happens in
our daily lives cost-effectively in the
not in the predictable future and the
real question is what are we going to do
with all of this information you talk
about information overload this also
becomes our intellectual property a very
fundamental nature and raises some very
profound social and cultural problems
for the country every one of us has the
potential for other people wanting to
see as much of this information as we're
willing to make available sometime in
the not-too-distant future there will be
the first woman president of the United
States and that person may or may not be
a little girl right now and everything
that goes on in that person's life may
be of interest to the country as a whole
but you won't know about it until that
event happens and so it seems to me that
if we were in that state we ought to be
making it possible to retain as much of
this information as individuals are
willing to allow to be retained subject
to their administrative controls so that
we do not lose our culture in the future
that's what I meant by digital fixations
also the ability to use this technology
to allow collaboration and teamwork I'm
gonna come back to this in in in a few
minutes but there is a very distinct
difference in view of what networking
can do depending on what business you're
in there's one one view of the network
as the medium for production and
consumption of let me say information
maybe it's content that is the idea if
somebody produces something of value the
network is the delivery vehicle somebody
buys it you pay for it transaction is
done this is trying to simulate the
buying and selling of the economy in the
networked environment there's another
model of the network where it's a medium
for collaboration it enables things to
happen that couldn't otherwise happen
for which there is no equivalent
counterpart in in speed and power in in
the physical world and it seems to me
that as we develop these ideas more
fully we're going to see these basic
assumptions about what the network is
having to come to the surface so that we
can deal with them both in law and in
terms of the whole evolution of these
systems in the notion of in cyberspace
that I mentioned earlier I think it's
going to be possible for all of us to
actually have a digital presence in
cyberspace today almost all of us relate
to it in one way or another I mean and
that relationship is varying at
different rates for many of us you know
when I first started using the network
in a serious way as a tool I found
myself initially going back to pencil
and paper because I was comfortable in
that mode because using the Machine I
had to remember too many things too many
things could go wrong and either quite
trust it or understand it well and feel
relaxed enough to just relate to it in
that mode and then somewhere along the
line it just became the natural way to
do things and then the paper world
became the the arcane way and for many
people I think they're going to discover
a presence in cyberspace that's
different from our current notion or
just relating to it is a place where you
go to pull things off a web or where you
go to send to pee
of email but you actually have an
existence there that's every bit as
important in some ways as your existence
outside of that space on the area of
open architecture again the issue here
is a very profound one for the
scientific community because
historically the development of science
has been predicated on the notion of
individuals doing the work and therefore
publishing their work in a form that
others can can review it when you're
trying to actually create infrastructure
oftentimes the full resolution of a
problem in all its details is an
inhibitor to getting other people to
adopt it as the very fact that you
stipulate an approach when there might
be a thousand different approaches is an
inhibitor rather than a solution for
actually creating the infrastructure
maybe an interesting intellectual idea
it may be a contribution to knowledge
but it may be an inhibitor to the actual
creation of infrastructure so the hard
part about infrastructure is excising
all of the details for which there may
be lots and lots of different and
alternative approaches that are better
than any single one that you might come
up with oh well you don't even know that
the one that you have maybe the best
allowing for people to participate in
that process if I can have the next
slide
okay I think the the real issue in
network enhancement is one what is the
network itself and number two what kind
of functionality are we willing to allow
others to stipulate for the network in
the case of almost every situation that
I dealt with people have shied away from
allowing other people to have a key part
in describing functionality they're
willing to take inputs but they're not
willing to let them take actions that
produce that functionality and so I
think this is going to be particularly
interesting as we get into issues of
learning in the network and by learning
I don't necessarily mean that to have a
scholarly notion as one might normally
attribute to that term but rather ones
that can incrementally update themselves
they can figure out what's going on that
can detect patterns of behavior do
things to improve things that that can
be that can be codified in the form of
computer programs that can cause
specific actions to take place that's
what I mean by by that term let me go
into this issue of this ubiquitous
content capture which I mentioned
briefly before if we have all of this
information that's around and we have it
all in digital form then we all become
intellectual property purveyors in the
most profound way I suspect that a few
of us in this audience have become aware
of the value of intellectual property
either by virtue of their selling
videotapes or by virtue of turning
things into books for sale or
what-have-you but when you actually have
all of this information about yourself
you don't know how much of it is going
to have value therefore you probably
want to protect as much of it as you can
from misuse by by others and this gets
into a topic that I want to spend most
of the rest of the the time on and that
is the issue of malleability
once you've got a system that's
capturing all of this information it's
going to be very easy to keep track of a
variety of things people have noted that
in the past Bush's paper was
particularly cogent on this particular
idea that you could settle things up you
could keep track of schedules building
links in the digital technology makes
that possible this is one of the areas
where I think the predictions are more
likely to come true and they can be in
various forms they can deal with money
resolutions they can deal with logistics
your schedules what-have-you and
furthermore the technology is all going
to probably become more integrated with
us I mean I can see the day when no the
threads in my jacket will be mini
antennas and you know if you want to
write on your display you'll just make a
little note in your inside of your
jacket pocket and I mean those notions
of their risks whatever probably will
come true in some way shape or form
because that's just progress in
technology but if I can have the next
slide I want to talk about this issue of
malleable content this is actually a
very fundamental kind of issue for
anybody who has looked at the way
copyright is handled today you realize
there are essentially two these two
distinct notions of the network the
network as the production consumption
medium for content where the idea is
that you can buy it you can have it you
can use it for your own personal use but
you can't really change it now there are
people who are willing to put material
out for use on the net and willing to
allow people to to change it and this is
not to say that that much of today's
technology can't be adapted to it but
the people for whom this is a business
generally don't want that and so this is
what I would call hard copyright
protection the extreme other side of the
coin is what I call no fixation
interchanges this is the dilemma of the
telephone versus the telegraph in the
early days when people thought that you
know telephone wouldn't fly because it
can give you any hard copy
and therefore it was viewed by summons
not being that relevant certainly for
business transactions but the fact of
the matter is that in between those two
extremes we're you know in the case of a
telephone call there is no work it's
just an interaction between two parties
it never gets fixed and the other side
where somebody actually creates
something that they say you can have pay
me don't change it there is a whole
world in between which I want to call
the world of malleable content and I
think this is where the real ultimate
value of the network is going to be
played out because it's a world that we
haven't experienced before in any real
sense now let me just say a little bit
about what I mean by malleable content
what I don't mean is that you take
somebody else's novel and completely
change it or somebody else's treatise on
a subject and create the inverse
although it's possible to enable that to
happen as well what I really mean is
where somebody can put out a piece of a
work into the cyber world and as a
result of that other people can then
build on that work in predictable ways
where people get credit for what they've
done and where the intent is to have
other people to malleoli manipulate that
work now this can be done in a number of
different ways but you know I'm
particularly impressed for example in
the discussions about education where
people think that the the task of
providing educational content is
providing things on the screen that you
can look at like papers and from a book
whereas in fact for kids to really find
that interesting they're going to have
to interact with that medium in a way
that's exciting to them just like as if
it were a non-fictional video game of
some sort so it's the interaction the
ability to cause something to happen as
a result of an action that you've taken
or a work that you've created that you
add on to the other one it's possible
that as we develop knowledge structures
for for use in various areas as time
goes on that people who develop new
knowledge in those areas can add that
knowledge to existing bodies of
knowledge therefore making the knowledge
malleable with time as we learn more
about
the interesting thing about that is if
somebody adds some piece of knowledge
which makes another body of knowledge
much more valuable it may be that the
real contribution has no meaning
whatsoever without the previous body of
knowledge that came before it and so you
can't really package them and sell them
separately they are intricately entwined
this is not to say that we haven't had
experience with this kind of thing but
generally the experience that we have
had is where people have put out works
of software literary works of software
and I don't mean that necessarily as
words but I mean symbols are in in
digital form where the intent is for
other people to use them and build on
top of them they may have certain
structures that not don't let you get
into the innards of them like operating
systems that you can't change but you
can use you know are the programs that
have the same or similar form but it
seems to me this whole idea of creating
malleable content out in the net is the
the thing that's going to make this
whole field really take off because it
empowers people to become part of the
process and contribute to do that I
think we need to back away from some of
our current economic notions of how to
pay for this because if the real value
of downstream contributions depends upon
licensing at all stages of the game it's
probably going to die in in legal
contracting world and in cyberspace the
fact of the matter is that we ought to
have a mechanism whereby the action of a
28 year old in Singapore need not bring
down an enterprise just because they've
distributed something in fact if 40
million or 400 million people actually
put their hands on this material it
ought to be that the party he generated
in the first place is reimbursed more
significantly for having done that so
I'd like to see that happen in the
context of the the last two slides I
think the whole idea of putting
intelligence in the net is going to
depend upon getting standard interfaces
into these Nansen I I foresee a day when
in fact we literally will have a single
means of interfacing one standard
interface
that lets all of the functionality that
interface be reflected in the object
that passes through it so that the
issues of plugging and the issues of
whatever are really grounded more in the
fundamentals of what you're trying to
achieve at the system's level than they
are at the physical hardware or
subsystems level if we can do that then
I think it allows us to deal with
entities that can move around fairly
dynamically can use different languages
can do translation because people can
inject into the systems the interfaces
that are needed to make this all work
now we may not call that intelligence in
the sense of you know traditional
definitions but I think it makes these
networks more malleable in their own
right and more functional in their own
right in ways that we can all benefit
from finally let me just say a few words
about notions of completely calm plex
systems which is where we're moving
toward I think that it is going to be
the case before too long if it isn't
already where no a single individual
really has any notion of the size or
scope of what's really out there what's
connected to what how anything is
working anymore just notions of the base
that you're building on and how to add
new functionality into it and I think
that as a result of that we're going to
have some serious concerns about
security we're gonna have some serious
concerns about performance and
functionality and in fact systems
collapsing of their own weight without
any notion of understanding sort of
where the weight distribution is in
these complex systems so I think we're
going to need as part of this matter of
developing this intelligence in the net
ways for these systems to describe what
they're about so that people can ask
them and those systems can then tell you
what they're about and how they're
structured where their strong points and
weak points are and so that we have a
better idea from the system's themselves
as to what's actually going on there was
a fellow that I used to work for who I
think was the last person who actually
knew all of the details
implementation in the bail system and
when he retired he said his fear was
that the whole thing would you know
possibly collapse if nobody else could
really you know keep their keep the
whole thing in their head of course that
really didn't happen as a technology
thing it happened as a political thing
and that's probably the more likely
event here that is will get to the point
where the systems in fact and explain
all of this stuff but it'll be so
complicated for people to then
understand it that they'll decide that
we need to rebuild remodeler eyes and
somehow restructure just so that they
can better understand it so the ultimate
challenge I think for us is to have
people understand what's happening who
are not technologists but who are either
users of these systems or ones who
depend upon it in some fundamental way I
am sure that if Bush had lived in a
different world and he had different
technology he would have envisioned a
lot of these things these are not unique
ideas these are not things that would
have been terribly surprising to him
it's just that when you're a very
practical person as I suspect
none of our Bush was that he tended to
rely on what was then and what he could
see in the likely and the likely
prognosis for the near term in closing I
would just point out that you know very
it's very interesting to me to observe
how in the short term almost everyone I
know is more optimistic about what's
going to happen and really does but in
the long term we're all much more
conservative about what's going to
happen then really does and I think this
is a you know somehow related to that
old adage that you know if you lose a
little on each piece and sell it in
quantity you make it up in volume so
just how that happens or why it happens
I do not know but it is a very strong
curiosity of our field that we are way
over expecting in the short term and way
under predictive in the long term thank
you very much
[Applause]
I wish I could afford to have that
perspective but but my perspective has
to factor in cost and I think that's
borne out by the fact that you said that
only maybe 60 million people are on the
internet worldwide and that's one
percent of the world population whatever
whatever there are people like John
Perry Barlow who wanted what basically
climb into their computers and live in
cyberspace and as this world that we're
building becomes more attractive to the
people who are there the tendency for
those guys to do that probably will
increase and so what I'd like you to
comment on is what's it going to take in
terms of cost drivers to get the 60
million to turn into six hundred million
or a billion before we end up with the
interesting societal pressures of the
the networked haves and the networked
have nots I mean I certainly do not
use as the only metric of networking
bandwidth or even connection bandwidth I
was giving that as an example have some
people measure you know progress in
networking and clearly their progress is
a function of cost and their ability to
afford that I think that we are going to
have to move to a service-based notion
of pricing before this will ever happen
because as long as the vested interests
are focused on existing revenue streams
you don't want to do anything to
jeopardize that I mean the the thing
that has been so profound in my view
about this technology development and I
guess you could say it for others that
have the similar characteristic is that
they're often brought to you by the
antithesis of the folks you would think
would bring it to you because it really
is challenging the status quo in many
ways John Mayo gave a one of the keynote
addresses at the National Academy
meeting in Washington last year and he
said it's a it's a true revolution in
the telecommunications industry and it's
only recently been realized and somehow
this this notion of the Internet has
sort of grown up around all of these
companies
quite know how it got there or what
happened but it developed around them
and now they're trying to adapt to it
and my guess is that if they're at all
smart they will try and be the provider
of the service for it
it wasn't something they have projected
in the first place because no one of
them would have probably taken the lead
in building such an open architecture
system if there are people who can in
fact afford to provide connections at
low enough price then my guess is you
will see them doing that only because
it's their way of getting a leg up in a
field that they otherwise couldn't
compete for and they will force other
people to have to deal with them and
once you get the cost of this down to
the commodities level becomes very hard
for third party folks to get in but then
you're dealing with base costs that are
probably you know about as low as
they're going to get my expectation is
that what we're going to see is the tall
pole in the tent grow taller that is to
say a lot more fabric on the tent and
you'll have a bigger base and you'll
have a higher tall pole which means that
the people who are working at the
forefront will be further removed from
the people who are at the base and that
you'll have lots more people at each of
the levels and that people will in fact
migrate from capability to capability as
they change jobs as companies decide to
make bigger investments and that we will
forever have a kind of a schism of
capabilities as people choose to buy
more and more capability as they can as
they can afford it
but that the price for getting in at the
low level will be reasonably affordable
this is a topic that we've dealt with on
the president's Advisory Committee a lot
universal access not necessarily
universal service and I know it's a
topic that's been written about fairly
extensively for those of you that the
black and white creatures in in Snow
Crash would would know I was just told
by Jim Rose that we have a very lively
and pretty large group in the outside
world that is following our proceedings
VI mbone and Paul Penfield's last-minute
inspiration which is his companion
system for letting folks on the web page
through the slides as each speakers
speaks to them on the screen here and
we've decided on the spur of the moment
that will allow some people to come in
with questions for the panel using the
whiteboard facilities of the mbone so
it's kind of nice to know that we're not
the only people taking advantage of all
these great speakers speaking about
great speakers I'm about to introduce
Tim berners-lee outside of saying ease
mr. www what else need I say some think
that the natural progression in
augmentation tools to use Doug's term is
the invention of writing then the
invention of the printing press and now
the web I submit this may be a bit of an
exaggeration but it's certainly the case
that the explosive growth of the web is
truly an amazing techno sociological
phenomenon there are a few things that
we can compare it to tim has been and
continues to be the prime mover behind
this explosion and I'm really happy that
he's going to be able to talk to us
today about his most recent thoughts
about the net and where it's going and
where the revolution leads next Tim what
a day
I mean this is it Annie this is great
I'm I feel tremendously honored to be
involved in it I've got some a hard job
coming up here and talking for
three-quarters of an hour following the
gurus of hypertext I feel a little bit
like a designer of a steam engine
following after with Boyle and Charles
and what sitting in the audience I feel
the same as Bob actually when I read I
read other Lanting monthly article again
struck when you do that you're struck
with two things you're struck by this
incredible vision there's credible long
distance vision and you're struck by the
fact that the guy was on the verge of
the digital computer revolution and he
didn't have awareness of that and he
still produced something which is really
very similar to
the things we're trying to make now even
though he wasn't didn't have the benefit
of that awareness of the digital
computer revolution it's interesting for
me to look also at where he's coming
from and sense of the the problem that
he's trying to solve that's interesting
because when you look at the
contributions that people have made to
the field of hypertext and networking
that they've come often from from
different solving different problems
that come from education they've come
for example Doug Engelbart with an
analyst and augment and to a certain
extent I would the web we're trying to
solve the problem of people working in
teams and Ted coining the word hypertext
very much from the literary standpoint
literary machines have got maya literary
machines booked here or autographed ted
nelson 92 8:24 which is in fact the
first place I read dynamics article so
looking at this the Memex article the
problem that he identifies is that of an
investigator of a scientific research we
have the first slide projected video on
great this investigator so the problem
he sees is of a scientific researcher
the investigator is somebody who has
narrowed his field down or her field
down I think in that case I have to say
it was pretty good corrector those days
to say his field down to the point where
he's still he can can't communicate with
other fields the specialization is
actually disabling the progress of
science and still he can't read
everything all the information which you
ought to be reading so that was the
problem that he started with but then if
you go to the end of the article you
find that he's really worried about the
the world as a whole he's worried about
the wisdom of the human race but and
being an engineer what he has produced
for the individuals problem is an
individual solution he's produced a
solution which is the size of a desk
which you give to the investigator he
has a problem you give him this thing
and it allows him to keep track of the
information so I'm gonna look I'm gonna
spend these few minutes so I'm not going
to talk about the web weather
was going or anything like that I'm not
gonna talk about it open architecture
it's like god this is the day off okay
so I'm gonna try to talk as Bob did
without saying anything I've said before
so you've got to be prepared for us
uh-huh
a lot of waffle and I'm not gonna give
you an overview slide either I'm so Ted
I think you're approved I just put this
thing together in a haphazard way and
I'm I did produce some overhead slides
retrospectively and I'm not going to
tell you about it so if you're out there
on the elbow and you've probably got a
link to them so pause for you to follow
it I'm gonna take their two things I'm
going to be looking at the distance the
difference between the the microscope if
if you like the individual solution and
the microscopic problem of the human
race
ah has this microscopic solution how how
to what extent is it actually helped us
solve the microscopic problem we can
take we can take that one that one off
we've flipped we're 50 years on we've
got the Memex know we can go back now
you can't go back you have to use them
have to go back using Netscape there's
some more and that was fun
that's where I want to be sorry you have
to look at me so we were fifty years on
and we're considering to what extent has
it actually made things easier now I
should perhaps explain when I'm coming
from I'm taking the Liberty as everybody
else has to sort of to put in a small
parenthetical piece of retrospective I
had well I suppose I still have I try to
write this talk to be cynical and it's
not in my nature so I think so forgive
me if I make a mess of it but in fact I
think we've seen it sort of fed of
bitterness system and which I don't
share so I maybe I'll try and turn that
off a little bit so I still have a dream
that the web could be less of a
television channel and more of a sea of
interactive shared knowledge the idea is
that
we are immersed in something which is a
warm friendly environment made of those
things which we have seen we have heard
we believe we have figured out and it's
interactive I met somebody just upstairs
over lunch who said that a few weeks ago
he discovered that in fact the worldwide
web program the original the the
original browser editor was in fact an
editor and in fact you could make links
as easily as you could follow them that
was fundamental it seems to me the two
things which seem to me totally bizarre
one of them is the fact that you can't
do that that we've lost that so in fact
the thing is not interactive I don't
know if I can think of any hypertext
experiments in the research side where
you haven't been able to make links just
as easier the authorship was really been
right up there and now for some
historical quirk which I could go into I
have gone into and I won't go into we
have a whole bunch of things out there
which are browsers so that's the first
thing I'm a little embarrassed about and
the second thing I'm embarrassed about
is the fact that of course when you made
the links and you edited the text on the
screen you didn't see any of these two
URLs and an HTML and all this stuff and
the weirdest thing for me if you can
imagine is to see an advertisement and
help-wanted of the Boston Globe saying
they want HTML writers or HTML
programmers I mean give me a break
it's like asking somebody to come along
with the skills to write a Microsoft
Word file in binary the whole thing is
totally inappropriate we have got past
there so so I'm assuming let's just
assume for the moment let's make a
thought experiment let's elevate
ourselves to the to the to imagine that
when we go back to our desktops to the
little mem X's which we have sitting on
top of our desks all these horrible
little things that in fact that they are
interactive you can make links so you
can you can spawn you hypertext objects
to just with it with a command Apple
splodge whatever it is so now we've got
that over with the reason that that was
put together was to be an interactive
way of helping people work together I
wanted to be able to work with people
who are off-site I wanted to be able to
work with people
who had a lot of enthusiasm not very
much time and zero travel travel budget
and I suppose also these people we were
working on technical things and maybe
being introverted technical people we
were sort of a little handicapped
socially and we would prefer in fact to
die for the keyboard and go make things
go type things and we'd like to do that
in an environment where we're all making
typing the same thing and the
communication happens through that
shared knowledge that was that that's
where I am coming from and I think it's
likely where Doug was coming from a load
at a time I didn't realize it term but a
lot of things yeah he says make me feel
all nice and warm and fuzzy so let's
just think about this problem it's the
team management problem you probably all
come across an organization a couple of
friends of yours though two of them and
they started up on a garage and then
there were before you noticed it ten of
them and before you noticed it again
there were there were 25 30 of them and
they were and it was great do you
remember those days and it went on and
the company expanded in there were 35
the product was really exciting and
there came a day when there were 50 or
60 between 50 or 60 of them and one day
somebody walked in and they suddenly
realized they didn't know everybody
there it was somebody's sitting behind
the reception desk who seemed to belong
there and I didn't know who they were
and at that point the project started to
go wrong and you've probably seen it
happen you've probably seen the people
start to leave and start their own small
companies because they gave up you've
probably read books about it you've seen
them on the shelves and the airport book
shows about the problem so this is the
team management problem if you go back
through history history is the history
of people trying to work together in
teams large or small and making a bigger
or smaller mess of it and with more or
less disastrous consequences for mankind
great tracts of it occasionally being
wiped out when people do it wrong so
this is a so this is a serious problem
and it's one of the but for particularly
for people who have who are trained to
look at nice malleable technical
problems which succumb to analysis
it's kind of kind of a challenge if
management of a growing team is a
problem in the class you can refer to as
management complete problems problems in
this domain do not succumb to technical
analysis in fact the traditional way of
tackling them is with a device known as
a management fad a fad is a it is a
heuristic algorithm which relies on it
has two basic properties one is that the
people who are implemented must believe
in it and the the second property is
that it must whatever it does it must
cause them to think about what they are
doing and the way it works is that
because they think about it in principle
in thinking about it they do in fact
make it better the solution to the
problem they would have made had they
not thought about it at all so here we
are when looking back at history of
people trying to trying not to as Bob
Bush put it perish in the conflict
before they can they learn a certain
amount of of race wisdom if we can with
our hypertext systems if we can make a
self managing team trademark we'll have
done pretty well if we can go further we
should realize that the process of
Education the process of politics and
all lists all these things are things
which we always we keep feeling we
should improve on we've got it there we
can set our sights quite high if we want
to and maybe within this room we can
quietly do that amongst the converted
I'm not sure about on the net so remove
that from the record so here we have mem
X's with more or less well it okay so
but they don't have the it the entire
space of knowledge that is relevant to
me stored in one side of the desk
because we get it over the net in
instead to a large extent there's a
certain change of parameterization and
the screen isn't slightly tilted its
vertical but basically we have mimics
there's new things glowing and glowing
in the corner and if we haven't made
good progress we'll keep working in
groups then clearly we can blame the
lack of lack of progress on the fact
that we don't have good collaborative
software we don't have good navigational
tools and the billions of people on the
earth haven't all got an
internet-connected computer okay it's
that right suppose they did apart from
the total horror of finding so many
years
Sydal Memex is around every corner it
probably drivers crazy with our problems
we solved anywhere ah would we be would
the race be empowered as a whole let's
think about these scaling problems I
think about some large numbers I think
about the number of documents on the web
let's think about the number of ants in
an ant heap Allah Hafiz data let's think
about the number of neurons in a brain I
think about the number of people on the
planet what is somebody quote it as 600
billion all these numbers of things and
the interesting thing about the neurons
and the documents and the people is that
they can all have these random
associations and we're talking about
random associations today because one of
the eye I'm talking about random
associations I'm making random
associations probably but the Memex is a
machine which allows you to to store
express and follow random associations
[Music]
the interesting thing about all these
systems of with many parts is that the
whole works the whole operates because
the parts interoperate and the way the
whole works and whether the whole works
is defined by how the parts interoperate
we can draw some analogies between these
things we can we can draw analogies I
suppose between hypertext links and
synapse is between hypertext links and
the relationships between people and we
know that if we take that as knowledge
is too far we have learned from
experience that you don't you people
behave in special ways which we have
great difficulty making data objects
imitate so but so we've been taught that
these are basically we've been taught by
experience so these are separate worlds
Wade Minsky might draw analogy between
the society in the mind but the neurons
and the people we treat differently and
the data objects on the web we treat
differently the neurons in the brain
on a good day seem to work as an
integrated whole
the people in the world on a good day
workers so several integrated holes on
various different scales the web
documents just sit there
now of course pretty soon they're gonna
start getting up and walking around
that's gonna be interesting
pretty soon we're gonna have these
things I'm at the moment you've noticed
the old one you bring over and it turns
a somersault and it's gonna get worse so
if you think that you're you know what
software you put on your machine you can
expect these things to start wandering
over and making themselves at home and
doing things for you on your behalf
which you may or may not approve of and
understand and bringing over their
friends to help and pretty soon you'll
be I mean you will be buying memory in
real time so so this is the way we're
going so the LeWeb objects are now now
becoming things that start talking to
each other and we stir and we have to
lay down some rules and the moment
laying down rules for web objects is an
attempt to try to get a document when it
appears on one person's browser to be
legible when it appears on another
person's browser when we have pieces of
object code running around this gets
more serious there are a lot that in
fact big pounds quite a big deal I've
the problem that I often have to
apologize when giving talks and I've I
started off the web project all in fact
using a web browser which had a
stylesheet by the way we have to sit
home even got back there yeah and I put
up a and I would be give the talks in
hypertext which meant I could take them
in pretty much any order and I got used
to that through rules which are the
microscopic rules if they're people if
they're between people we call it a
constitution we call them we call them
laws we call them codes of ethics if
it's between particles in a gas we call
them that the rules of atomic
interaction if they're between web
objects we'd call them protocols let's
let's look at some associations with
Association as we draw as we're drawing
parallels I saw the next one we've had
it before Association connection that's
what this little thing produced when you
type Association into it these are their
associations with Association ties and
link what what associations do we have
with Association what links do we have
with link what this is the first
Association people have with link give
them hypertext and for a long time the
sister so 1989 you suggest hey folks put
in hypertext immediate reaction is no no
no no no hypertext is very very
confusing you'll get lost in hyperspace
and so one way or another we managed to
get the system out and a little while
later people say hey hey hey
links a cool man and the click here
Brigade is seized the public in from
imagination and been seized by the
public imagination they're rushing all
over making these way cool links and and
that and that was a phase and then the
link now implies a readership you make a
link for the guy at the end of the link
this is interesting to him we haven't
even got the Xanadu and we got we
haven't got trans copyright but still
the guy is very interested in his
readership you make a link and number of
things happens the guy use ego goes up
his sort of citation rating goes up he
starts checking the referrer field and
he starts logging to find out what sort
of people are reading his stuff and he
starts to and pretty soon he starts
writing within the document a profile of
the people he's found the right that an
exploration of how many people and you
find these little counters have you seen
these little counters on the web that
you come across saying no this document
is about by the way you were the three
thousand four hundred twenty first
person to read it close parenthesis so
the link comes to mean readership and
then for some people now the Association
is the link with the dollar now that's
an interesting one now it's not yes it's
an interesting one because it means that
there's all this commercial stuff
pushing the pushing the web technology
and and it's
the world upside down and it gives it a
sort of a slant which it hasn't had
which didn't have when hypertext was a
good old academic field but it's but
what's interesting about it is that the
link is the unit in hypertext and the
dollar is the unit in one of the
simplest models of the Micra government
the behavior of people so we've had two
systems we had the behavior of people
which we generally regard as something
which computer science ought not to get
just computer scientists ought not to
get involved in and we have the behavior
hypertext which for a long time other
people felt that people human beings
ought not to get involved in and we
haven't kind of linked together and this
suggests to us that in fact we should
not simply talk about hypertext and
evolve - hypertext and Douglas is
mentioned early before the phrase
coevolution I think it was there was a
graft you remember the graph it had the
system's evolving along horizontal axis
and they had the human system so
evolving on the along the vertical axis
now when we put a something like that in
that links in fact the most boring part
perhaps of our society the economic
system the marketplace it's the simplest
thing to model up to a very simple
element of the hyper hyper text and of
course there's a whole lot of of impact
one on the other the one would show
people hypertext and global hypertext
there's there's an impact there's an
emotional impact they feel empowered
this for those of you who are not a
native we're not sorry I can't see
Native Americans I'm not an American
English speaking and in power
empowerment it's a term which is crept
up in the 1990s which is sort of tune it
it means so the feeling which you feel
for example when you first see global
hypertext but and at the same time but
you get misgivings and you get fear you
get despair for normal healthy life
quite rightly so and of course and the
web is influenced by society as well
even though we have tried to build
something we've tried to build an
abstract space out there which is full
of objects and these objects just sit
you know totally in a space without
anything supporting
they're not digital fixations as Bob was
saying of something real they just exist
once you've got it they're in a
cyberspace you can refer to it what you
do you refer to is that some sort of it
with a URL which has got bits of domain
name in it and it's got an inside it's
got other things it's got some a little
bit of semantics it's got there's some
reason that the name was made and then
there's a social change social change
that somebody that is that a company
changes its name or it splits or it
drops the project torus or somebody
moves from a company from one company to
another and the document suddenly gets
another name we got broken links so the
social change is suddenly disrupted we
have a fault line through cyberspace
because in fact we had a social there is
in fact in there it is based on a social
arrangement names are based on the
social contracts between the people who
issue names the people who use names so
these things two things are really
interested in to intricately connected
when we're and the reason I would
suggest that we haven't made tremendous
advances in solving the world's problems
is that we now have to do engineering of
as Doug says the human system and the
computing system at the same time but
now we're not engineering the mimics now
what we're doing is we're in fact we're
engineering the greater machine which is
made out of the links we're constantly
changing these microscopic rules
physicists are interested in the way the
microscopic rule if you invent
microscopic rules you can then deduce
the macroscopic behavior and what an
engineer creates microscopic rules and
creates macroscopic infant behavior and
for people governments are changing the
laws they're tweaking them here and to
Hume there and hoping that people will
follow them on the web
organizations like the World Wide Web
Consortium are introducing new aspects
to the protocols and hoping that people
will follow those protocol
specifications and these protocols no
who cares about protocols nobody cares
about the about the protocols but they
care about how the whole system behaves
they care whether when everybody tries
to if we if we put up the URL of a slide
in their hundred people watching and
they all go on access a slide in the
server
100 hits at the same time or if it's a
shoemaker Luke levy commented you too
bitter they can't it can't handle
100,000 people hitting the same thing
place at the same time they're
interested in the fact it doesn't work
then all interests in the protocols and
then we change the protocols underneath
and so the objects can migrate about
through them through the network and get
ripped and be replicated we've changed
the overall macroscopic behavior we can
change its tolerance to faults we can
change its availability in its response
time the weight scales when we're
looking at the goals which range between
me for the interesting things that for
society their goals are often expressed
in microscopic terms a goal of society
is that it should be fair that any two
individuals should have a fairness
relationship there are right to right to
free speech to health clean water and we
also have constraints on the whole we
have those constraints on the whole of
society that it should be stable
it shouldn't wipe itself out we
shouldn't have we should the safety of
the race should is important to us we
have to try and satisfy both of those
whereas for the way I've been general
we're in the little protocols don't
affect us but we are also interested in
things like heterogeneity the fact that
the protocols will work independent of
platform these are microscopic rules as
well as the macroscopic rules that the
whole thing should work if anyone links
where links should be cut
when we do this engineering what we're
doing is we're creating a different
topology we're playing with the topology
we have our exes now we can make links
what's the topology of the result when
we make the big machine out there
what's the topology what's the topology
of our society what's the topology of
our hypertech's going to be and as we
design things in engineering we come
across a number of interesting things
interesting useful properties that in
the internet world for example the
internet world anybody who's come
through there
he's totally sold on decentralization
the internet works because it's
decentralized you can start an Internet
network anywhere and then you can
connect it up to the big network without
too much of a horrible frightful change
when you do that the same with the web
you sell a webserver anywhere you can
start a little web and then when you
connect it there's I mean tanked it up
to the new one there's only an
incremental change so and Internet
people have come through this if you
look at the internet Engineering Task
Force you'll find a whole bunch of
people who've come through with a pretty
strong political anarchic decentralized
view as well they just decided to take
this from one since the philosophy from
one system and apply it to the politics
as well and you find that for example
the news groups on the Internet have no
home they just exist in the network you
can't pin one down a news group starts
somewhere I guess but and so do the
articles and they propagate and the
network sees to their propagation and
everybody ends up with more or less the
same view but there's no one particular
home so as something which I think just
an example of one sort of general rule
that we've picked that we pick up
there's another one I could give a
number of examples of the rules I could
give a number of examples of decisions
that we're having to make right now as
we designed the protocols which could
seriously affect the topology of the web
and that could effectively seriously
affect the topology of society and an
interesting that this decentralization
is in fact often a myth in fact I should
say in parentheses because very often
you have a nice decentralized system and
it all works courtesy of at another
level there is a centralized a totally
centralized system which is policing it
so the web is totally decentralized and
then but it does use DNS space and DNS
the domain name system address space
this WWF ooh comm is in fact a singly
rooted tree now in fact it the web
doesn't make any assumptions about that
so in fact the web behaves them socially
decentralized fashion but it does rely
underneath on a centralized system and
when you see people happily going to the
market and bartering and chatting and
talking to each other and exchanging
goods for money and what have you now in
the marketplace on a Saturday morning
the reason that it all works in such a
nice fashion is that there's a policeman
standing on the corner by the statue and
behind him there's a hierarchical system
going up to the Supreme Court in this
country so which guarantees that but
when you're talking about the
marketplace we don't discover we would
don't discuss that but then there are
other topologies which do scale well
when you look at them you take off the
hood and they looked underneath they
have the same properties they're
basically fractal remember fractals they
were popular for ten years ago there's
next slide I went looking for a fractal
picture I wanted something which
Illustrated something which was
basically Frank which basically had
scale and basically it didn't I went two
clicks from my homepage and you see
we've got two things the interesting
thing at the bottom of the trees we like
trees we like trees because they've even
though they're not in color they have a
kind of a shape and they have a sort of
a tree structure now I'm not saying that
fractals of course the most interesting
ones are not trees it kind of rolls
simples example but then when you as you
zoom in you find that there is an
interesting structure at every level by
comparison look at the building we have
dominantly
a one of the scale of about a hundred
meters we have a rectangle as we zoom in
we see nothing until we get to the one
meter level which we see another
rectangle and then we can zoom in
probably until we get to the rivet level
we won't see any more detail so this is
basically in a nutshell to hope the
problem with modern architecture it's
not fractal and if you apply two
protocols it's very interesting to make
protocols which are fractal we want if
we can find a design which scales in the
you can for example make a structure in
your hypertext which works at a lower
level and use the same
structure at higher level whether you
wear you'll lose the detail then that is
very interesting it has these
interesting properties it had good
scaling properties think about society
to society have this scaling properties
yes it has structure and lots of levels
it has an international structure it has
national structures state structure it
has structured by field is people are
structures into guilds and groups and
families and people and when you look at
the microscopic effect what's it like to
actually be in a fractal environment
because after all if we're trying to
make a fractal we environment for
hypertech's we can't decree that it is
we can't say right you should make of it
we can't design it as a top level we
have to only make the protocols we have
to design for example sets of link types
or we have to put in transclusion or not
put in transclusion we have to make
little decisions at the microscopic
level and hope or demonstrate that that
will lead to something with interesting
topological properties so let's think
about society what does it feel like to
be in a factual situation it's essential
every human being needs to be in a
fractal environment every human being
needs to be part of a structure at a
small level at the meet at the family
level at the next level out and to have
some feeling for where things are going
on a global scale everybody needs to
have some links some lots of local ones
lots of not so local ones not so very
not so far distant when you're putting -
you're managing a big team an
organization planning those things so
that there are communication paths of
different lengths is very important I
call it information plumbing sometimes
it's really really crucial when you've
got when you're trying as the consortium
team is a good example we've got all of
research on one side and all of industry
on another and we're trying to allow
good ideas to filter through and we've
got some key people we can recruit in
various places and we have to put in the
plumbing decide ok this person is going
to talk to this many people at this
level this many people are that level
it's information plumbing and when it's
done well people feel comfortable that's
interesting isn't there that a human
being feels comfortable when they are
when they have interactions at a wide
but widely diverse scales maybe human
beings are programmed in some way such
that when you put them together
they will interact so as to form
something which has got this factual
properties maybe their program they
maybe this coming about three evolution
because animals that didn't work like
that died out they couldn't make a big
big society work they couldn't make the
society scale I noticed Bob made a
remark about the problem that no one
person there was everything in the
system one of the interesting things
about the fractal property is that you
can move from the small scale from from
the specialized area you can get out and
get into a big line without following
too many links following a finite number
of links you can get back to anywhere so
that we're looking for a system one of
the properties of this and we need is if
there's a problem as a solution there's
got to be a finite number of links
between them so I think I'd go into
there to my time and can we go on take
that to Pauline building off so what are
we heading for we're heading for making
local decisions which have global effect
we're making decisions all the time like
ANFO sentence some at you what about in
to end confidentiality is it reasonable
to for two agents whether they be object
for people no matter where they are
geographically located to be able to
communicate without other agents be the
objects or people being aware of the
communication that's the nice little
rule we can lay down it'll can determine
the topology of society it can determine
whether you can run a police state it
can determine whether terrorists can in
fact set up shop and and and pull down
society and this is up for this is up
for grabs now it's up it's being
discussed by Congress and ever and
technologists and lawyers they're all
over the place should we put in should
we assume the trans copyright model what
would that do suppose we do that what
would be the global effect should we go
for something much more complex which
would have lawyers involved very very
much more
what about what about the right to
anonymity all these little things week
there little microscopic rules we could
set up we set up the microscopic rules
anonymity confidentiality we could do
that with a protocol we don't have to do
it with the law we can do implement the
protocol and then we have a look at
society so these are real these are
rules that we have we have rules about
existing about the web at the moment we
have a rule for example that there's a
basic rule that defines the usefulness
of a URL if I dereference a URL and I
get something and I'm interested in the
thing I get and I give you the URL
that's got to be as good as giving you
the object when you dereference it
you've got to get in some way even if
you want to get a black and white copy
you've got to get the same thing so we
have a rule about that we have a rule
that when you get something that Matt
may not have side effects with these
rules because you can start deducing
things about the system and you can
start making more sophisticated systems
you can allow you to do caching and this
sort of thing when we go into the world
of mobile code of secure systems network
payment these principles are being laid
down sometimes silently sometimes amid
uproar they're going to define the
behavior of the new machine of the big
machine of the new anthill of the new
brain whatever it is which is the sum of
our selves and our data we have the next
slide and always the question is can the
applications of science can they allow
the investigator to encompass the great
the great record and to grow in race
experience can the whole human race grow
out of this or is it a just question of
check ease having fun thank you for
listening
thanks so much Tim okay we now have some
time to probe a little deeper anybody
wants to ask please go to the mic and
identify yourself
and don't forget we have a panel session
at the end of the afternoon if you don't
get satisfied just now
Michael Michael asked you talked about
the question of whether we want
anonymity as a technical one and the
problem is that in fact this is one
where the legal process is moving very
strongly we've got variety
sorry I'm being directed we've got a
variety of people in politics who
somebody referred it to once is the the
Four Horsemen of the net child
pornographers drug traffickers foreign
agents and terrorists and the question
is whether can we answer that list by
all means but one of the questions is we
have to think if we decide that there
will not be anonymity on the net will we
have a better chance of staving off some
worse thing that the politicians might
do to us or not
and I happen to feel that at the moment
that's probably the best thing to do in
the realities of the situation but I
don't really see the right debate
technically from among people over you
know how many of these things can we do
and what should we do I think my my
thesis today is that you can't
distinguish between the technical
question and the sociological question
so anonymity could you can put anonymity
in simply by setting up a proxy server
where the required characteristics and
it's been done
and so you and you've made a
sociological decision by doing that well
by at least by throwing away the logs
and so we could go into these various I
think that we will be a rathole if we go
into them too deeply are you asking me
to say whether I believe in anonymity or
not
so say you repeat it for me and I'll
repeat it for them
yamir servers I didn't catch what I'm
saying here is if the technologists get
together and say well yes someone can
build an anonymous server but will
refuse to exchange traffic with it
we can probably stamp it out I mean lot
there are lots of technologies that get
stamped out by legal means there's you
know we're pretty far along at the
moment to abolishing nuclear power
childhood vaccination and birth control
research as a combination of legal and
political aims I'm worried that the
internet might actually be more
endangered than we think yeah okay well
my first answer to that is it is a very
good it's very appropriate for
technologists to produce protocols which
allow people to behave reasonably so for
example if if there is pornography on
the net which is quite a good example at
the moment there is no way of declaring
that of covering yourself and make
allowing the server to say to the client
hey this stuff is bad stuff I want you
to take full responsibility for the fact
that you over over 18 you're not gonna
show it to anybody else
before you sign up if we put in some
protocols which allow people to behave
reasonably and to flag that and behave
more as they do in in real life then
that probably that may stave off a
backlash people trying to stop stamp on
the whole thing because it's just
unreasonable and and that backlash would
be totally totally reasonable if you
make protocols which don't allow people
to behave reasonably then you're set
you're creating an unreasonable system
and in this particular example for
example the the w3c has a initiative
called pix platform to Internet content
selection which is doing exactly that
it's putting technology for allowing
people to label things allowing third
parties to label it
to label things allowing teachers to set
up filters allowing everybody to protect
children and and incidentally being a
lever for allowing labeling of all sorts
of metadata of all sorts of interesting
types and that will make the internet
the web a whole lot nicer place and it
may be that when it comes to anonymity
the same sort of thing my personal
feelings that probably when you browse
the web I would like to be able to do is
browse a number of modes with a number
of different persona so that I can
eyebrow either browse anonymously or I
can browse as me with my name or I can
browse if I have to browse through a
catalogue for example they will or I'm
if I browse a magazine which has got
advertising in the magazine will
probably not want to know my name but it
will want to know how old I am what
salary range I have how many children I
have my shoe size and whether I have a
backyard and this sort of thing so I may
want to be able to switch between those
persona and we would need to lay down
rules which prevent people the
principles which say that you're not
allowed to tie these these two things
together even if you do manage to even
if you write programs which can which
allow you to piece these two things
together there are codes of behavior
which say that if I can give you this
information I'll give it to you on the
following terms so it in the same sort
of area we can lay down from some
reasonable ways of operating we can
define protocols which allow exactly the
sort of negotiation you you you
mentioned whereby you you may be
browsing anonymously you get to
somewhere so sorry we don't take
anonymous people you know if you want to
come into this door you take the hood
officer
well and that's perfectly reasonable
that's reasonable behavior we need to
allow it we said we made protocols for
Paul Kahn I want to ask you a question
about your comments on topology because
it's recently come up in our work and it
was also one of those things that in
some of the hypertext systems previous
to the world wide web was of great
concern and then everyone was amused
that it didn't really exist
in in the world wide web in that a link
and href is an href you know URLs a URL
doesn't really matter where it is you
want to make a link from one thing to
another you just it's the nice thing is
it's simple the not so nice thing is
that it may be the fastest way from
Singapore to Hong Kong to Australia back
to back to MIT but
as you move from one place to another
you often have no sense of the topology
of the structure of the content of the
material there was nothing in the way in
which things were coded or precious
little in the way in which things were
coded that gave you a sense of where
anything was in relation to anything
else and I was wondering if if you're
suggesting that there needs to be more
of that built into the into the coding
or you're just suggesting that we'll
discover that it's there oh you bet I
mean we've got a ticket a lot further
than that - ah I have to confess that 10
years before writing the World Wide Web
I had a program which I developed
personally for my own use which had
links and it had typed links and that
originally the web there was an href and
there was a relationship equals and
there still is in some of the specs
there's a rel equals and in fact in some
cases you see it used as a relationship
between a document and its author but
when you moment you put aloud put type
links and you can do two things with
them one of them which addresses I think
your question is you can make structure
so you can make relationships you can
say this is a table of contents this is
the links in this are basically I intend
as a trail so that you can you should be
bring up some browser gadget to allow
somebody to go backwards and forwards
through these legs this is a table
contents is a summary of that you can
make relationships between the documents
and the other interesting thing you can
do which is maybe more interesting is if
you regard documents as being
representative of things people concepts
if if they are in fact information about
something even if it's another document
but about any arbitrary concept then
when you make relationships between
these things you can make relationships
state relationships between the objects
you're talking about that becomes very
interesting then we have things like a
Quinet we have all the hypertext systems
which have had which express argument
for example which I would express the
legal reasoning where there is semantics
in and then and I think that perhaps
people have a band of semantics because
they felt that hey you know we can't
sell the I problem so let's give up but
in fact to put
some semantics into the web would enable
so many things there are so many
applications which become trivial when
you invent a few link types you can
represent the whole thing as a bunch of
linked objects it would enable computers
to help you because the computers could
read the link type at the moment reading
as you say it's got a bunch of slides on
this I said I made them and 14 months
ago and I give them every now and again
if we use that rel field then instead of
it just being a mass of objects with
these anonymous links between them then
the links actually start to take Lynch
time significance and you ask questions
you can say ask interesting questions
like okay suppose this guy dies what
about what are all the things which he's
written which have not been done which
have not got which are not described by
documents which he is also written which
are used by things which are recursively
transitive closure of used by things
which are used by anything which I'm
relying on and to do an interesting
traces like that to ask logical things
for the network so that then I think
we'll take that make the web very much
more powerful it'll allow people to put
information on which has got which has
got semantics which in which computers
can then use to actually help them and
in all this it's great system for
communication between people but the
computers are all part of the
infrastructure and some people like to
think that one day the computers will
actually start to participate to other
people don't I've given them up there's
some people there are a few computer
scientists and AI people back out there
who think they're Monday the computers
should have a presence on the net - Ron
Becker University of Toronto I want to
go back to your original goal of
facilitating scientific research which
is very much in the theme of the tribute
to Vannevar Bush could you describe what
you regard as the one or two major
dramatic successes in the use of the web
to facilitate scientific research or
describe what you think are one or two
major limitations that you think would
have to be overcome in order to attend
to your original goal well I'm
unconscious as ever of course of the of
the limitations they
the big limitation is the fact that the
thing is not interactive so the original
idea that we could share knowledge and
and annotate each other's and and make
caustic hypertext comments on each
other's documents which was which is
really interesting in scientific
environment for example in people review
or in anything in back of an envelope
writing is it's just not there the web
has got this strange publishing model
that is in a sense trivial to fix it's
in a sense so so for the purpose of this
talk I've assumed that it's fixed but in
the sense we know exactly how to do it
and we've done it it's been done
trivially it's drivel in this in the
sense that we have to try to put produce
persuade people who actually make the
leading products that they should give
this to people they should replace the
HotList metaphor with something which is
that that if they want hot lists
you should have hot list objects on the
web and if you want to have hypertext
objects you should have it if you you
should be able to edit hypertext objects
but basically another thing which you
can read see you ought to be able to
pull apart and manipulate then it that
it's difficult to get that across it's
difficult to get it across because the
commercial push is from the people who
are disseminating information who are in
output mode so and but I have a lot of
hope because I know that the online
services for example they all started
off saying hey what we're going to do is
sell information you'll dial up with
your telephone in your modem and we'll
sell you whatever information you like
and what they found was they want that
people want you to talk to each other so
people really like to type and they like
to import they like to be part of it and
I think that pretty soon in the moment
that for a really neat hypertext editor
comes along that's integrated happily
with you with the workspace and all
these other funny things on the on the
screen there I think it's gonna be it's
gonna be a walkover he's gonna wipe the
floor the competition
I'm about to fall off the edge of the
table
[Music]
[Applause]